[Applause]
[Music]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the leia hill plan show so
today is going to be a lot of fun but
before i introduce my guests um this
particular episode is sponsored by
coincorner the uk and europe focus
bitcoin exchange that offers very
lucrative bitcoin cashback when you shop
online it's even up to 40 with some
partners and they have over a thousand
different partners and merchants so
pretty cool all you have to do is just
add the browser extension
and then you can get cashback when you
shop online in bitcoin which i think is
great so i'm gonna leave um a link for
you guys somewhere um in the description
um and there you go just just go for it
all right guys so today before i
introduce my guest please don't forget
if you are watching on youtube don't
forget to subscribe and hit the like
button so you never miss any of these
interviews so joining me today is the
host of cnbc's crypto trader and the
host of your beloved youtube channel it
is ran nuna of crypto banter nearly
stumbled on it there how you doing ran
how are you
i'm good how are you doing
fantastic fantastic another great day
another another quiet day in crypto with
this litecoin news litecoin walmart news
i mean just when i thought i had my show
all cut out one month before
the news breaks
it's garbage
so i had to put it all together but
we're good
well since you bring that up let's just
talk about it because it literally just
happened litecoin did in fact spike 20
and then it dropped
what do you think happened was this
somebody trying to do a quick pump and
dump or was this a genuine kind of
mistake
i think it's much more malicious than we
think because
i think what they showed now is how easy
the entire crypto market is manipulated
and if you kind of think about the
substance in the news and to be honest
when i first heard the news i warned the
guys at the office i said look this
doesn't sound right because
if walmart
it would be very logical for walmart to
adopt crypto that's like obvious yeah
but it would be
crazy for them to adopt litecoin and i
don't mean that with any disrespect to
like coin community but what you would
do is you would adopt a basket of crypto
currencies because the switches are all
exactly the same and you'd say we have
you know we're starting to accept crypto
and you'd accept bitcoin as the most
accepted crypto in the world you'd
accept bitcoin on some kind of lightning
channel or something like that so i mean
it was suspect but when cnbc confirmed
it and reuters confirmed it and i mean i
looked at there's nothing hold on it's
it's not like it's it's cnbc it's
reuters it's gotta be news so i laid out
the whole show now we changed the whole
show to be a light coin focused show and
then as the show went live we started
seeing it maybe fake news so we had to
go back to the
to some kind of mix of between the
original show and the litecoin show
but you're not so weird people are now
calling for more crypto regulation just
because of this
well i i
but i'd be interested to see what's
going on
that's what it was about it was about
showing how easy it is to manipulate the
crypto market so people like gary
gensler
are looking at this and going you know
they've got now another bullet in the
arsenal to say to us hey guys you know
you want a bitcoin etf and you want a
litecoin etf but look how easily
manipulated the crypto market is where
one new story can drive the price up ten
percent in in a matter of fifteen
minutes and then five minutes later all
the retail hands get get dumped uh and
get stopped out and that's exactly what
happened in fact i was looking at the
liquidation stats on litecoin and i mean
they're crazy like the number of people
that got stopped out and liquidated on
litecoin was insane
what do you have the numbers
uh yeah i can quickly call them up for
you uh what it shows though is a system
which we've covered before on our show
um
a system
of how to manipulate crypto so what you
do is you go to a a good sounding so
let's look at the the quickest quickly
look at the one hour numbers
um
okay so those are the one-hour numbers
so you can see
that read them out read them out because
people will be listening on audio about
a million dollars
worth of litecoin got stopped but when i
was looking at it i was looking at the
number of accounts so it's all small
retail hands accounts that got stopped
out and that's in the last sorry that's
the last hour hold let me take you back
four hours because that would so 25
million
got stopped on litecoin um
143 000 litecoin so this is the people
that were stopped
the number the clue is actually in the
number here where you see that there's
151 000 litecoin that were actually
stopped 151 000 accounts that were
actually liquidated and the vast
majority of those were like coin
accounts
that's so insane just showing how easy
it is to manipulate the crypto market
and that's the sad thing
that is unbelievable i mean
what would be more interesting for me
would be to see some actual journalism
and some fact checking
because when you've got people like like
reuters and cnbc confirming this i mean
reuters and cnbc that was my telltale
sign that this thing might actually be
real
you kind of believe something but the
formula is simple you go to a newswire
that sounds credible and in this one it
was called global newswire it sounds
like i think it was globe i think it was
globe newswire as opposed to global
it sounds all credible
yeah and then all the other all the news
artists pick it up because they want to
be the first and they kind of fomo into
breaking the news and they do absolutely
no research
and then by that time this fake news
actually become real news you know by
that time the fake news actually is real
news
and yeah i mean
then the crypto markets have been
manipulated and it's the poor retail
investor that gets stopped out
so with a very small amount of money you
can destroy and wreck retail investors
that's insane so when you say um you
know these are people trying to prove a
point about how volatile and immature
this market is you genuinely think that
this is for this came from a malicious
place this came from perhaps people
trying to prove a point that it does
indeed need to be regulated
correct that of people that wanted to
get out of a litecoin position which
doesn't really make sense and if you
watch the markets bitcoin went up and
like so litecoin went up first and then
bitcoin went up
so
i mean
yeah absolutely it's sad it's a it's a
it's actually a bad day for crypto it's
a bad day for crypto it's a sad day for
crypto because we're gonna get
sorry go around we want the markets to
be filled with integrity and we want the
markets to be sophisticated markets and
good markets and when this happens it
just you know all the hard work that we
do to bring credibility to these markets
gets killed and it's that it's it's
someone in crypto it's sad that there's
so much manipulation
i know there's manipulation in every
market in the world in gold in oil in in
everything else but you know crypto
because the market caps are so small is
so easy to manipulate and specifically
when you manipulate crypto you
manipulate against the retail investor
so
you know the retail investor is the one
that gets hurt arguably when stock
markets are manipulated it's hedge funds
manipulating and liquidating other hedge
funds here it's the retail investor
that's getting blown out the water by
fake news
so what's the solution to this are you
pro-regulation then
i am pro-regulation
um i think i think if you if you think
that
crypto is going to remain unregulated
and i mean let's just rewind what do we
mean by crypto remaining unregulated the
fastest way to transfer assets around
the world at the lowest possible
commission with no bureaucracy
whatsoever
if you think that that industry is not
going to get regulated you're living in
a dream like it's it's it's not not an
option it's going to be highly regulated
now i'm all for regulation but i think
it's going to be logical regulation it's
going to be regulation for the right
reason
the type of regulation that we saw with
the infrastructurable garbage you know
um uneducated uninformed
politicians
lobbying for points
inserting
um
unthought through regulation into
another bill
that's not regulation but i do think we
need regulation because that will bring
more money into crypto and ultimately it
will protect the retail investor
so i want to learn more about you ran um
i don't know loads um and i want to go
back a little bit before crypto before
before those days um
you're obviously um based in south
africa um you've done a lot you're um
you know you do work with cnbc but i
really want to understand what you did
um before crypto you know in your 20s in
your 30s what was life before crypto
i'll take you on a little journey so in
my 20s i've always been a crazy
entrepreneur
built and sold many companies
in
1998 i raised a lot of money from a lot
of people to start an online stock
broking stock broking portal um i raised
a lot of money i was i was set to become
one of the youngest internet
company directors on the stock exchange
here
um
we were building in the internet bubble
and in 2000 when the bubble popped so
did our company and so did run so run
became run was broke
broke to the extent that i had to go
back and live with my parents
broke to the extent that i had to
mortgage my car
broke to the extent that
i couldn't afford to go out to
restaurants because i didn't have money
and i couldn't be bombing with my dad
anymore just like it was embarrassing
how many times can you take twenty
dollars from your dad it's it's
embarrassing
um so i was down and art
so i threw myself a
probably a three-month pity party
i didn't do much i had a pity party
and
then i started looking for things to do
and i had a girlfriend who was doing
what we call in-store promotions that's
you know when people do you know alcohol
promotions or toothpaste promotions in
inside supermarkets
and i went to visit her in a store one
day and a few things happened the first
thing is she wasn't there which showed
me that they
monitored the second thing is i saw 60
other people doing in-store promotions
um and they were untrained and they were
terrible salespeople and i thought hold
on i could do this better and i started
a marketing agency and it became the
biggest marketing and sales agency in
africa
fast forward 15 years
i sold that to a company called publicis
in the biggest media and marketing
transaction on the african continent
promised myself i was going to retire
found bitcoin
went down the rabbit hole
and
that began my crypto life
so i started investing in in many crypto
companies and in between wait wait wait
but how did you find bitcoin how did you
how did you discover crypto
um
so it came to me from a couple of places
but in late 2014 early 2015 a friend of
mine said
i'm bi and he's always been like you
know every group is like the early
adopter friend like that one friend was
a gamer and he's always uh
and he came to me said i'm buying this
magic internet money and it just keeps
video magic internet video game money
it's called bitcoin and it just keeps
going up in value
you know i'm a dj gambler so i was like
okay well if it keeps going up in value
buy me ten thousand dollars worth of
stuff
and then i bought ten thousand dollars
and it doubled and i was like hold on
it's the easiest money ever made buy me
another fifty thousand dollars
what was this
this is end of 14 beginning of 15
december 14th
this is when it all started and i
started buying bitcoin um
just not knowing i had no idea what this
was other than the party line which was
this is magic internet money yeah
um
and that began
then i was starting then i started to
hold the stash of bitcoin
you know when number go up you start
realizing you started reading about what
you actually bought i must admit i first
read about it i was like why do you need
decentralized money like what's wrong
with government money
which i think is a big point
i think the ordinary man in the street
doesn't really understand the need for
non-government money like nine out of
ten people
can't see why the government is is is um
is detrimental to money management like
no one sees this or specifically at the
time in 2014 and 15 we didn't have this
money printing through covert
i think maybe now people are starting to
wake up but we've got to remember that
nine out of 10 people still don't
understand the need or the concept of
non-government-controlled money it's a
complicated concept because there's no
reason why the government shouldn't
control money to most people it's only
the few people
you know the one out of ten which is us
in the crypto community that have
started to educate ourselves as to why
the value of money has been dropping and
you know what and what the fed has been
doing
and yeah so that was 2014 2015
in 2016
20 sorry in 2017
i went to cnbc and i said look you know
you got to be covering this asset class
it's called bitcoin
bitcoin yeah right it's scam money it's
a ponzi scheme it's i mean i heard all i
heard all the buzz lines
and then eventually i met a friend of
mine as one of the directors i met him
about something else and i educated him
about bitcoin and i think the penny
dropped for him and he said look don't
speak to my head of production
so i went to the head of production i
spoke the head of production
and you know when you teach people about
bitcoin and there's that like one second
where you see their eyes light up and
the penny drops
yeah
so i was like i saw that look in her
eyes i saw like i saw she got it
like i gave myself a pat on the back and
i said i obviously did a great job
teaching her about it
and so i said look guys
you got to be covering this as the class
and she says yeah we do
we need to have and all i wanted them to
do was actually to cover it on power
lunch or squawk box or whatever just
like for three minutes
and she said this thing needs to have a
weekly show
it can't be three minutes it needs to be
26 minutes and it needs to be live so i
was like great good luck with that if
you need me call me and she said what do
you mean he said you're doing the
and i was like hold on a second
weekly
big commitment
yeah remember i just sold my company so
i kind of had the time
26 minutes that's a shitload of content
in 2017. and live i've never done tv
before in my life and you want me to sit
there live
and she said look you'll have a
production team and we'll teach you how
to do tv
so i arrived back there the next week
and i've got a production team but i
realize the production team doesn't know
much about bitcoin so like they gave me
stuff to look at i was like no you can't
say that that's not bitcoin no one
understood it
so i said hold on i got this and i
phoned a whole lot of my friends in
crypto phone brock pierce spencer bogart
and i said listen next week wednesday
ten o'clock in the morning or whatever
the time was
i'm gonna send you a zoom link and then
you're gonna be live on the first
televised crypto show in the world
on cnbc and that's how we ran the show
and i looked back at my first shows i
was terrible i'm still terrible but i
look back at the first shows i was
really terrible
i was you could see me reading off the
prompter like this but i mean i got
through it and i got better and better
and
now we are we are where we are today
that's such a fascinating story it's so
interesting you know that this happened
all the way back in 2017 because even
then i think that is so early i think
you know even now we have we struggle so
hard to get mainstream news outlets to
even talk respectively um in a
respectful way about bitcoin as we've
seen you know with the el salvador and
and all that news coverage that i got um
but right now you're doing an amazing
job with crypto banter um you have one
of the most incredible communities um
the most loyal community everybody it's
like one big family it's truly amazing
so i'd love to understand how you built
that and you know how you're able to
create something so powerful
okay so
i realized a few things when i came out
of cnbc and so i ran the once a week
show with cnbc and i realized a few
things one is once a week is not enough
for crypto show because the market moves
way too quickly once an hour is maybe
not even enough for crypto show because
the market moves absolutely too quickly
the second thing is i realize that
crypto people don't trust
cnbc as a new source
facts they it has credibility
in other stuff but they don't trust it
in crypto they used to call me the
counter indicator when i was at cnbc
they said cnbc is the county indicator
when cnbc says buy you sold
the third thing that i realized was
crypto people don't relate to suits and
tires
they don't want a guy in a suit and tie
talking to them in a studio sitting
there with his posture with his hands on
the counter and
and protect they want you to be who you
are yeah
and that was the biggest lesson that i
got
that if i'm authentic
transparent
honest
with my community then they will
trust us
and
the more authentic we became
and the more we realized that actually
the whole reason why we're doing this is
about community and we don't actually
care we've become absolutely selfless we
don't care about ourselves we do not
care about ourselves we only care about
the community
we we make sure we get allocations for
our community we do give away we gave
away like a million dollars in a week
two weeks ago to the community no how
did you do that we got offered
allocations in ideos
right we decided to instead of taking
their locations first to take them and
to get the entire community
and the allocations came onto the market
at 50 100 200 x and we just gave it to
the community and we said and we did it
at pre-ido prices
so even though we knew what the price
was we knew they'd done a 30x or a 40x
we still gave them 100 each in pre-rdos
so
what i realized was and it's actually a
big lesson in my life for me it's
just give
you don't need any more i don't need
anymore like i'm not i'm not very
wealthy on international levels but i
don't really need any more and i get
much more joy and passion
giving to the community and when you
start to give
selflessly transparently authentically
without expecting anything back
this the biggest thing happened this
community just became loyal to us and
they became like a family
and we saw this when my producer's
father passed away he passed away from
covert and the community was like we're
like his biggest support structure
and then we brought a new member into
the family who's a trader his name is
sheldon
sheldon was a carpenter who lost his
father less than 12 months ago
he was broke he had to sell his
carpenting equipment but he realized he
had a gift for charting and i discovered
him and i said you know what i just want
to i want to just change your life
and i brought him onto banter and i said
banta fan meet sheldon and i told him
the sheldon story that sheldon story has
been viewed over 300 000 times on
youtube and they love him and he's part
of the family and we've got this like
banter fam family where the family
explodes every day all we do is give all
we just give
we never ever ever our motto is we never
ever ever ever ever take money from our
community for anything
no money from any member of the
community ever for anything no
subscriptions
no
no paywalls
nothing we even we have a school
i pay teachers we created a syllabus the
school is free it's we're going to put a
million people through school by the end
of 2022 and it is free it's costing us
money but we're going to put a million
people through crypto school in 2012 by
the end of 2022 for free what does
crypto school look like
it is 100 people per class
live classes you get
you get it put into groups of 10 in the
class
uh there's three streams
the first stream is an introduction to
crypto investing and that is uh starts
off with a history of money
goes into uh understanding
centralization
understanding network effects
bitcoin
bitcoin versus gold
yeah ethereum
altcoins and bitcoin disruption
uh
exchanges and wallets
security and scams and then it ends off
with building a crypto portfolio and by
the end of the first module all we want
you to do is to be able to have a
conversation about any altcoin and be
able to build a crypto portfolio and if
we've done that then we've achieved our
objective that's stream number one
once you've graduated from street number
one you can be accepted into stream
number two and that is making a career
out of crypto so if you want to know how
to speak if you want to know how to
analyze tokenomics if you want to know
how to chart if you want you know
there's so many different ways to make
money out of crypto
so we are we'll then take you into what
we call sniper school and that's like
the second scripter school then sniper
school where you can make the the most
accurate trades
and then we teach you trading staking
psychology of investing um
you know
different portfolio strategies stuff
like that
and the third stream is a separate
stream which is crypto for institutions
and that is uh how do i reward my
consumers with crypto how do i accept
crypto where do i store the crypto uh
what are the positives or the the
negatives uh you know where do i keep my
crypto treasury stuff like that so it's
three streams
uh and our objective is a million people
by the end of 2022 and all three
that's incredible i love that so much i
find the information right now is that
there's such a barrier to entry because
the information is so difficult and also
there's just so much information so
people don't really know where to start
so having a place where people can go
um and just have everything
organized into some kind of educational
format i think it's great it's amazing
that it's free um but i want to just
tell you i think i did tell you um but i
want to let your um your audience know
as well
talking speaking of how big the banter
family is a few months ago i was just
out having breakfast somewhere in london
and um this guy just sitting next to me
was just watching you on youtube um and
he was like do you know do you know do
you know rand you know crypto banter and
i was like yeah yeah i know them um
and then you i think you'd used one of
my videos on your show
and then he doubled it
yeah and then he doubled takes and
looked at me twice and he was like
that was you
and i was like yeah that was me so it's
such a small world i can't believe just
some little place in like the outskirts
of london i was just sitting for
breakfast
you won't believe how popular crypto is
in it and like when i go for a run in
the mornings in in new york or in miami
i live in miami so when i go to york or
miami and i'm running people spot me
when i entered the us the tsa official
that actually checks you in
oh that checked on him and he tried to
keep it
see he was like looking at me and like
and at the end of it he said so what do
you think should i be buying bitcoin or
litecoin right now i'm like how do you
know i watch you every single day so
it's like i think like there's just
people everywhere that watch you and
again i think it's
because of our attitude where we just
give it's free we don't want anything
back from the community except maybe a
like and a subscribe um
and we're authentic we disclose all our
holdings we tell people when we invest
um
you know we don't we have a lot of rules
like you can't sell any token if you've
spoken about on the show for i don't
know i don't remember the numbers but
it's like 48 hours so we can never pump
in our community so we're trying to
build
i want to take on cnbc
not take one i want to run a parallel to
cnbc
i'm going to have
you think about the traditional
financial world
you can switch on cnbc or bloomberg at
any time of a day or night and within 30
minutes you've got you know exactly
what's happening on the markets from a
live credible source
with crypto that doesn't exist
with crypto
you have to go to twitter and good luck
finding credible information on twitter
then you have to go to telegram and i
don't know what your telegram looks like
but if it's anything like my telegram no
chance
so there's no way to get it there's not
one button where you can go live
credible 24 7 365 streaming of crypto
content and that's the market that i
want
live not in for long form i want to be
live if you want live information that
is credible 24 7 365 go to crypto banter
that's what we're building we're going
to take on cnbc we're going to become
the parallel in the crypto universe and
one day we're going to buy them
damn i love it i think that's amazing um
but i want to delve into altcoins with
you because you know a lot um your
followers say you know a lot so i want
to go into i have a lot of questions so
you said recently that you
sold your ethereum for seoul
is that correct yeah i sold about 60 of
my east and i put the money into solana
and i put the money in between twenty
five dollars and about fifty dollars
actually eight i bought some more at
eighty dollars at about eighty dollars
okay so talk me through this a lot of
people say that solana is the ethereum
killer
why why does it have to be the ethereum
killer and
for it to be an ethereum killer
they have to be direct competitors and
are they
well it depends how you see it i think
what we've realized let's talk about
what ethereum is let's understand what
is it there so to most people ethereum
is a smart contract blockchain that's
how you see it
to me ethereum is a call option
on multiple different blockchain
experiments which may all disrupt the
world
so if you think about the two
that have succeeded out of the hundreds
that have happened
one of them is d5 and the second one is
nfts
what we have realized with the with d5
disruption and the nft disruption
is that if any other experiments are
built
we're going to need a lot of blockchain
capacity because if you've seen what
nfts have done to ethereum they've made
ethereum not usable
arguably nfts are in the beginning
beginning beginning of their life cycle
we haven't even seen one percent of the
disruption that nfts are going to do and
the biggest blockchain that we have by
market cap
can't handle the transactions to the
extent that it is
broken useless and unusable to the
majority of people right it's it's it's
it's unusable
so with that thesis in mind
i'm not saying that they're going to be
ethereum killers but i'm saying there
probably are going to need to be a whole
lot of blockchains that are going to
work
then i worked i worked on who are the
blockchains and what chance they've got
of success
so for a blockchain to succeed you need
great technology
you need a developer ecosystem which has
like like the reason why ethereum worked
is because all developers believed in
decentralization and that ethos so you
can't have a centralized blockchain
and then you need money you need vc
money
yeah so i look at solana
has vc money in the form of sam bankman
feed multi-coin capital and a whole lot
of investors
it has incredible technology it has the
the fastest technology that i know for
smart contract blockchain finality
it is decentralized enough and it is
scalable
so that's when i when i realized that
and i saw what was going on with nfts i
thought you know what i know that i'm
i'm passionate about ethereum but i'm
actually going to be a big boy and i'm
going to say you know what
i like it because i'm emotionally
attached to it but logically solana has
to work
and solana worked
and then i looked at cardano and i said
hold on
uh love carano great technology
so lifeguard honor because if you
understand the technology on cardano
corona is very sophisticated technology
that makes blockchain very simple
okay so karana is going to make
blockchain very simple and corona has a
lot of money behind it um it has a very
very very loyal community in fact only
now we are seeing that the solana
community is staking more than the
cardano community yeah and as of
yesterday
cordano has smart contracts
so now you've got two very viable
options but celana has much more
traction than cordano and so that's why
i put a lot of money into solana and a
little bit into corano and then i bought
a little bit more of avex because i said
look we need a lot of
smart contract technology because none
of the layers are going to be able to
fill it up and avex is the one that is
up and coming and so i put a small
little bit on avex
so that's my thesis around smart
contract blockchains and i do believe
that they will all succeed and there
will be space for all of them
and i think
that in the long long long term ethereum
is going to be the biggest
underperformer
you think the thing which gets me about
these blockchains is they're all doing
very similar things
and
it's very difficult
i find to really get to grips with you
know the the the detailed intricacies
which make them just slightly different
a lot of them are working on you know uh
interoperability a lot of them are
working on smart contracts d5 nfts daps
you know the whole thing
um so when you look at something like
solana and a lot of people say it's the
ethereum killer how does that then
how does that then compare for example
to binance smart chain because a lot of
people were saying back in april during
the peak of the bull market that binary
smart chain is going to completely
destroy ethereum even though it's kind
of like a copy of it
so how where does binance marching come
into it for you finance smart chain
binary smart chain is a tricky one
because if you look at the bnb token
it's a token for an exchange and it's
also an exchange a token for a smart
chain yeah so it has it's i mean it has
its pros and cons
on the one hand if the exchange fails
the smart chain will work if the smart
chain fails the exchange may work so you
may have be you know
diversified
on the other hand
i don't know have you ever used binance
smart chain it's a clunky experience
i use it just for like trading and if
i'm on like pancake swap or something
like that
experience it's because it's a fork of
ethereum
it's much much much more centralized
than ethereum and much more senseless
it's it's very cheap
and at one stage a lot of people are
building on it
but if you want decentralization
and you want to go from i don't know 20
or 30 validators or whatever the number
of validators are on the binance smart
chain to 700 validators which makes it a
lot more decentralized then you go to
solana
from a speed point of view
celina has blockchain
finalization in 0.4 of a second
and they do this through a piece of
technology where they've embedded a
clock
a watch clock into their technology
so and the reason for that is most the
time blockchain
systems are working out what came first
and what came second they have to agree
on what happened before what what solana
did was embed a clock
and said you know if you've got a clock
then the clock tells us what came first
and what came second
and so they don't have to argue about
what came first and what came second and
they don't have to reach that level of
consensus which makes the line of the
fastest blockchain out there i don't
know of any blockchain that settles
transaction faster than salina
but you said you think
say that again sorry
i don't know any any blockchain that
settles
finality faster than solana
but you said that you think ethereum
will
come last in this race which is really
interesting because obviously there's
ether 2.0 coming
proof of state coming
eventually
yeah do you not think that's going to
change things a bit
do you not think ethereum still has that
first mover advantage so that when if
2.0 does come you know
it might sort of kill the other
competitors
interesting question so
traditionally i would have said to you
that each cannot be disrupted
and the reason why it cannot be
disrupted is the same reason why bitcoin
can't be disrupted and that is because
it has network effects so for people
watching we don't know what network
effects are
it's like a it's like whatsapp
with every user that joins the network
you can make more calls in the network
and therefore the network is worth more
exponentially so if leia and i on on
whatsapp the maximum number of calls we
can do is i can phone layer and she can
phone me that's two calls if we add a
third person then you know fred that i
can phone leia leia can phone me i can
phone fred fred can phone me
freaking phone layer and so we increase
the number of calls that can be made on
the network exponentially yes
once something has network effect
the rule is that it cannot be stopped
and in fact even the growth of it can't
be stopped so it's
it's the reason why investors are so
happy to pay a premium for facebook for
amazon for google because they all have
network effect
so there are only three things that can
stop a protocol that has network effect
in the world
government intervention is one so if the
government says hey bitcoin is banned
ethereum is bad you're going to stop the
network effect
the second one is a
um
a breakdown in the technology
so i'm going to park that one for a
second okay and the third one is a
competitor which is 10x better has a
small potential to be able to steal
market share from the incumbent
so traditionally i would say that any
protocol that has network effect can't
be stopped
but in this case i think ethereum has
been
on two of the three axes
actually may be stopped one is the
technology doesn't work it's just not
fit for purpose
right and it's fit for purpose at a time
where lots of vcs are allocating money
to blockchain development because
they're seeing just how promising
blockchain development is
yeah
so they are taking their money from
ethereum and they're putting the money
into celina
right now right now we're seeing a huge
shift of money from ethereum to celina
the second thing is that celina may
actually be 10 times better than the
current east product so great you've
promised us this east 2.0
but the problem is you're taking too
long to get to market
and because you're taking too long to
get to market you're opening the door
for disruption
and so it's very very interesting that i
think that
in most cases
even if you have a slightly better
technology
you cannot break the network effect but
in this case you have a better
technology and you have a technological
failure and therefore i think that
ethereum is at risk of being disrupted
and then you add on one more thing and
you say
this blockchain disruption
is so big
that no layer one is going to be able to
handle it on its own
and so there's space for more than one
and then you go back to who's got the
best technology the most vibrant
community the greatest ethos and the
most money coming in
and
solana maybe cardano um yeah i mean
that's that's where the money is going
i sort of look at it as
similar to social media platforms yes so
you could say in some sense
when they were first built people
the developers didn't necessarily know
that twitter was going to be built for
journalists and let's just say
intellectuals or whatever you know
people that like want to have that kind
of debate and that kind of conversation
i don't think they had that in mind as
opposed to
you know facebook being built that way
and instagram being more picturesque and
i don't think they had that in mind i
think it's kind of
how
they evolved naturally based on what
their algorithms could do and what their
technology could do and i sort of see it
like that and i think that they won't
necessarily all survive
but i definitely think more than one
will survive i think it's just arrogant
in my opinion and ignorant to think that
only one blockchain will survive
um
i am talking across the mark i think 10
blockchains will survive maybe even more
bitcoin is going to survive and it's
going to be the ultimate store of value
it's got network effects the technology
is great it's proven it's been battle
tested a million times it's amazing
decentralized so bitcoin bitcoin is safe
yeah okay then we move on to smart
contract blockchains
ethereum
very decentralized eth 2.0 will be
amazing when it launches
um but it's still not fast
it's still not 0.4 of a second to
finality
now that's okay for
large-scale default transactions
institutional d5 transactions where
you're more worried about
decentralization and security than you
are about speed
okay so then this will be a great
blockchain for that
what about the traders who need
split-second speed
celina
what about the what about video gamers
who need split-second speed because
that's the game
solana
so
different blockchains will do different
things and i think the nuances are going
to become
you know cardano and ethereum are going
to be a little bit more centralized than
uh decentralized in solana so people who
really need decentralization as the as
the key access
security and decentralization
we'll go to the ethereum guys and that
is we'll go to salina
the other thing that we not talking
about here but we should talk about is
bridges
um yeah right now token bridges are
clanky like it's clunky it's a it's a
yeah it is it's a terrible experience
it's like
bridging a token from one place that it
gives you anxiety you've got to take two
xanax before you bridge them and then
you hope the tokens come out on the
other side and that you have an input
inputted something incorrectly and i
mean yes
even just sending a transaction no like
even just still sending transactions
still gives me anxiety because i'm like
is it correct did the copy paste work is
it going to go to the correct address
it's not wrapped it's the actual legit
coin it still gets me really honestly
the polygon somatic polygon bridge to
get yeah chromosome to polygon is quite
quick but when you send the tokens back
from polygon to ethereum like because of
the ethereum system it could take like
hours
many hours
so if you're sending reasonable amounts
of money
and you have to wait hours
i mean i just sit there and i'm like
when is this money gonna rap when is
this money gonna arrive when is this
money gonna arrive so right now bridges
are clunky they're not user-friendly
they're getting better but they're not
user-friendly and there's a lot of fees
associated like you've got to wrap the
token one transaction and you've got to
send those into the token over the
network another transaction
but that is going to become almost
seamless in time that is going to become
almost seamless so i think
there is a massive
play on bridge technology
and there are good bridges out there but
people are discarding how important the
bridges are from hopping from one
network to another network to another
network to another network and one day i
think all these bridges will just be
interconnected
um
i think so yeah
speaking of which interconnected we
don't talk about polkadot and kusama
which are just this i was going to get
to
go on but all these specialist
blockchains and that for me
i was sitting this weekend and i was
thinking
you know this blockchain disruption is
so big
and no layer one can handle the
transactions so who's going to win
and that just thought to himself who is
the most scalable blockchain of all of
them
another what's going to be kosama or
pocket because what they do
is they connect a whole lot of
specialist blockchain so they connect
like a moon river is the ethereum
equivalent which is ca it's it's a it's
a it's ethereum but plugged into kusama
and just think about ethereum one and
ethereum two and a theorem three and
then a special d5 chain and an ai chain
all plugged into one bridge so you got
100 chains and they're all plugged into
one bridge and they transact seamlessly
on what they call the substrate network
which is the kusama network
and to me i just that's when i realized
just how big and how scalable the kusama
network and the polkadot network will
actually become
so i mean no one's talking about these
yet but i think that those two are also
like
the two horses that are in the race
you know it's like a horse race and
they're like
we're like in the beginning of the race
and they're all in the pack
but looking and going hold on that's the
horse that's going to break out at the
end and i'm going to give it like a big
run at the end and i think that's what's
going to happen
i totally agree with you i'm looking
into all those projects that you
mentioned right now kasama substrate uh
polka dot i'm looking into all of them
investing probably more than i should um
but whatever my mind is going to lose
value anyway if i don't invest it so
that's kind of my mentality um but you
kind of did just mention it you know you
spoke about scalability decentralization
um but what are the main kind of um
i guess trends and indicators that you
look for
um when you're
wanting to
find something new to invest in
follow the smart money
what does that mean though that's like a
cute catchphrase but like what does it
mean
so what i've realized is if i look at
avex avalanche and i look at r-weave
which is in my mind one of the one of
the you know the best blockchain
protocols out there um
what i realized is that the smartest
money in the world and the smartest
money in the world like andreessen
horowitz polychain capital pantera
multi-coin capital
these are people that have a lot of
resources
they spend a lot of time researching
things they have a lot of money they see
a broad view
of the industry
and they decide to put big bets on these
things
as a retail investor that's your queue
to be jumping in
that's when it says follow the mark
money
you know i mean i get a taste of it
because
because we're in the in the media
we see a broad range of projects and
because i have an an
analytics team on analyst team who
research projects for me
i get a taste of what it must be like
selling it and recent we've also got a
lot more money and a lot more access
and a lot more research than i've got
and it's a it's an amazing place to be
so
for me the the
the
follow the smart money just
follow what the big fans are doing try
and get if i could do one thing all day
long just understand
where the big fans are allocating their
money and understand it as quickly as
possible because you know everyone's
talking about avalanche
and recent
has funded avalanche for three rounds
the last of round if i'm not mistaken
was last year 2020 when no one even
spoke about avalanche no
you know um if you did your research
you'd know that he was funding it and
yes
it was pretty simple it was i'm going to
just try and find it first but um
avalanche i'm gonna share your screen
again
let me just find it and recent
andrei
now you got the solana price up there i
like it
on the price up later so uh let's have a
look here yeah so uh here we go i mean
this is
june
2020 june 25th 2020 um
base layer was heat up with another 12
million committed to ava labs ever
launched blockchain avalanche and and it
was led by galaxy by andreessen by a
whole lot of others so
you look at this and you go hold on
what did they know a year ago that we're
only finding out now
then i'm with you
yeah so then follow the smart money
follow the smart money because you'll
never have the resources to do
to catch up with their resources so just
follow what they're doing
so what projects are standing out to you
right now
other than celina
um so layer one block chains so cordano
solana avalanche layer one because i
don't think we have enough layer ones
luna
the terra luna
uh ecosystem because of the adoption
because of the genius of how their
stable coin works if you understand what
terra luna does so some people call it
luna some people call it terra
there's a stable coin that they create
which is called terror no yeah or you
know i don't know which of one is a
stable coin uh it's the terra is a
stable coin i think the terrorist yeah i
was going to say the terror is a stable
coin terrorist
and
they create applications which create
use case for more terror
and the more applications that they
create the more terror need to be
created to meet the demand of consumers
right
so the more consumers you get the more
terror you have to create
in order to create terror you have to
burn luna
which increases the supply of terror
so
you're watching this this ecosystem
where they are creating more and more
and more amazing applications that are
going to create more and more and more
users into the terra ecosystem and
require a whole lot more terror to do
that they're going to have to burn and
reduce the supply of luna
so it's a no-brainer because they've
just started and they've got a market
cap of 4 billion dollars i mean whatever
the number is i haven't looked at it
today but
no-brainer
yeah i've been saying it since 35 cents
now 35 people are starting to listen
um
that for me is
a great ecosystem another great
ecosystem for me the best i've been
calling it again since 7 cents and 10
cents and 35 cents are weave
mm-hmm
are we was the most genius thing
in the world
i decided i'm about to swear on your
podcast yeah you can't it's chill gone
so it's it's
when you understand how genius are
weavers
so
you talk about file storage
file storage is a flawed industry so for
one
every file storage provider in the world
charges you per meg per month per gig
per month per terabyte per month blah
blah blah
yeah
and the information is not stored
forever and i know this because there
were articles written about me less than
10 years ago which i look for on the
internet and they don't exist
and that is because probably a good
thing
well yeah some of them are great some
especially some of those photos um
so
what our weave does
is
they are a blockchain so to speak
and what they do is they store data
forever with one payment
so instead of paying every month you pay
i don't know what the number is but call
it ten dollars per x and then it is
stored
forever
how
they have an endowment
and what they do is they they they
charge you and they've worked out what
they think the the cost of storing data
is going to be
and they've added like multiples in it
but remember this the cost of storing
data constantly gets reduced
because computing power gets cheaper
storage space gets cheaper
and they've done the calculation
and they take the money
and they have a very sophisticated
consensus algorithm
which says to the block manufacturers
now the block manufacturers
in this case have to store data and they
say look if you store
the data you need to store
plus
some other random data which which it
asks you for and if you've got that you
get the payment
so you're incentivized to store as much
data as possible
and through that mathematically they can
guarantee you that your data is actually
going to be stored forever
and so if you think about
other blockchains or other storage
protocols either google controls them or
amazon controls them or they may not be
around forever and then you say hold on
if i'm buying an nft i'm buying a punk
and my
cost me a couple of million dollars and
i want to hand it down from generation
to generation to generation i want it to
last forever
yeah i'm publishing a world-changing
life-changing
journalistic story
i wanted to be there forever and not to
be able to be deleted and i wanted to be
there for another thousand you know when
when they brushing off
our news like like we do with the
pyramids and the pharaohs i want it to
be
i want it to be there forever and
there's actually only one system of
protocol in the world that does that and
that's our weave
so anything that is super important to
you
should be stored on our weave
and there's no competitor it's not like
oh there's another one no one else does
it
it's what's the technology well it's
like was it like proof of stake like
what is that it's
they have their own consensus algorithm
they've got a it's
it's a
consensus algorithm where you have to
prove that you've got that you've stored
x plus some other random stuff and i
remember how they they what they call it
but
that means that everybody that stores
data stores it forever
yeah and
and again are we people just haven't
realized the power of our weave except
now with nfts where people are storing
nfts there because they're being stored
forever another one
is solana
realizes that they've got to store their
data somewhere
where do they store the data on iweave
oh really where do you store blockchain
data the only place to store blockchain
data forever is on our weave and so
solana is storing their data on iweave
and i think many more blockchains will
follow so for me are weave no-brainer i
mean
come on you gotta be done
i don't know i i need to look this up
now i need to i need to do some uh
dyor do your own research yeah so yeah
for me luna solana are weave um karano
uh the leia wands and then i mean you
gotta have a speculative portfolio i
think everybody must have a speculative
portfolio um where you can have some fun
um
well on that point i did ask people
earlier um what their questions were for
you i had one fun one which i thought i
have to ask um which kind of fits
perfectly right now somebody said if
ryan had to put his entire life savings
on one coin he thinks will 10x by
christmas
which one would he choose my entire life
savings on one point that will 10x by
christmas wow
hold on let me let me look at the
portfolio
oh damn
that but i wouldn't put my entire life
savings on any coin i think that's just
negligent
i think dot hasn't run yet i think dot
hasn't run yet which is which is
uh risky let me know which is which is
good
wow life savings one coin
probably somewhere in the dot and kusama
ecosystem i think that's good
are we of luna
yeah the rest of the risky i'm scared to
put people into very risky coins because
no you don't have to no it's not
financial advice it's just it's just
what you would do you tell them one
thing portfolio and they put 90 because
they think that's the coin and then they
get themselves wiped out
yeah you've got to be careful with that
um another question that came through
was um what price um
let me let me actually read it word for
word because it's written kind of
readily um what price did he pay for his
first btc and his first eth
first btc
somewhere around 500 don't remember
exactly but somewhere around 500
my first east
it's between six and nine dollars i
think i missed the idea i bought between
six and nine dollars
damn um okay somebody's actually i'm
looking through the um live chat now um
i wasn't looking earlier but i'm looking
now um and people are asking about link
and i can't believe i've not brought
that up i'd actually love to hear your
opinion on link link is amazing um as an
oracle solution it's got network effects
as an oracle solution
um yeah that's not i mean i have link in
my portfolio but it's not as exciting as
it's really not as exciting as some of
the biggest coins you know some of the
most exciting coins it's going to be a
fundamental part of every portfolio but
it's not like
it's not one of the coins that i think
is going to change my life or triple
before christmas or you know i can't see
them taking over the world so i mean i
mean it but
i wouldn't be putting my life savings
into it no way
okay and then another question that i
have which is quite a funny one as well
is um how many times have you been rock
pooled
uh
yeah many many many i mean i i sent
is you're gonna laugh
i think i sent
don't quote me on the numbers but i
think i sent like a hund you know like
200 bitcoin to a fake bitcoin mining
scam in 2016.
oh exactly i'll give you that
yeah i mean they gave you a guarantee
that they were doubling you they would
double your bitcoin and
my friends were all drawing their
bitcoin and i jumped into the ponzi and
i caught him with the number he gave him
200 bitcoin which at the time was like
200 000
and then it took they took my 200 000
the next day they shut down the website
so i've been writing so crazy i've been
ranked in d5 i was involved in some of
these hacks where where i had tokens in
liquidity pools or in pools where they
were hacked but i mean that's part of
why we make the 100x returns because
we're going to take more risk and
every now and then things are going to
go wrong and we just have to be we have
to put on our big boy pants
so
some more questions are coming through
i'm just going to i'm going to take two
more um and then and then we'll and then
we'll leave it um somebody's asking did
they miss the boat on seoul i imagine i
know your answer to this but go on
i mean
if you talking to me about the next week
or two weeks i can't answer that but in
the long term i don't think we haven't
even started yet i think if you're gonna
hold it for three four five years
you know i bought solana on my show live
on the show for forty two dollars
everyone told me i was crazy
um and then
it went back to twenty two dollars and
people started to hate me on twitter and
they said ah you bought you know forty
two dollars and we all bought after 42
dollars
no one's crying now
no one's
you know no one's crying anymore it
depends how long your investment horizon
is
um
i tweeted that i said you know people
are talking about whether smart
contracts will be a buy the rumor sell
the news on korano
oh yeah that was me
i tweeted that
who the is like quran is not about
today or tomorrow or next week or next
month
i mean even if smart contracts didn't
work they would fix it and next week it
would work you know like who cares
you're not buying blockchain technology
for today you're buying it for the next
five years of disruption
and so like you think you've missed the
boat on solana now
come back in five years then then you'll
see what what missing the boat actually
means celina is valued at one-seventh of
the value of ethereum
okay is it too late
there you go there's your answer
so just finally then on um a personal
note what's your goal with everything
you know crypto wise and work wise
um just to change people's lives
change touch touch the lives of everyone
that comes into contact with me
my my
i've just got this thing of like if you
spend every single day of your life
thinking about how you can
change other people's lives somehow it
has to come back to you and i can say
that i'm trying to change the life of
every single person that works with me
my producers my
my team my analysts
my um traders
just you know we get allocations i give
them all the allocations uh no i don't
think anyone has taken a salary like
it's just one of those things where they
make so much we just give everything
away that they don't actually need their
salaries um then i want to change the
banter community's life and then just in
general like
i've got the means
to change people's lives i don't want
anything in return i don't need
yeah more money would be great but it's
not about more money um
so just change as many lives as possible
and then watch other people
who some were down and art and some who
weren't having a great time and just
watch them smile again and watch them
like the fan mail that you get you
changed my life you put me out of debt i
managed to pay my my kids studying
you know no fuss car no yacht
would give me the same amount of
pleasure
as just changing other people's lives
and so
hell just change other people's lives
and don't ask for anything in return and
don't expect anything in return
and
yeah that's the aim the aim is just to
ch to touch and change as many lives as
possible
and do it for free
yeah and i think you'll do it with this
crypto score i mean you're doing it now
anyway with crypto banter but with the
school with you know one million do you
say one million students or users by the
end of the year of next year yeah
end of next year yeah
yeah that's amazing we'll have to i mean
i know we chat anyway but we'll have to
catch up as well when that's when that's
you know going and because i think
that's amazing
i'm getting you to do a 10 minute show
on banter and you're going to start
and it's going to be like it's called
microdose and leia's going to do a few
and she's going to fall so in love with
the banter community and then he's going
to want to do it every day and
eventually is going to do a daily show
unbanned for 10 minutes and just give us
the microdesk i know it's going to
happen i can feel it there you go
oh i have one like one last question um
i saw on your show today you were
talking about wife changing money what
number is that
um it's not a number it's a it's you you
need a lot of money if you're
life-changing money is a big number i
mean you know how expensive wives can be
right
well i'm not a wife but i can imagine
when i am one i will be a pricey one so
yes
just for the record i don't want to
change my wife i'm i'm okay i'm happily
married i don't want to change my life
but it's a great term that we've that we
use a lot i like it i think it's
brilliant when i heard it i was like
yeah yeah that's brilliant you won't
believe how many people send this mail
and say you know it's a derogatory mail
how can you keep saying wife changing
money why don't you use the term has
been changing money um
why is changing's better we also on the
show we did like we broke up the tokens
into categories we said are there a
one-night stand
uh it's like you know slap me around and
then let me go in the morning
um
like we said like don't leave a
toothbrush which means that you've got
to get in you've got to get out the same
day like you can't leave a toothbrush uh
and then we said like date me
uh
commitment and then like marry me coins
and like bitcoin
and you won't believe how many emails we
got like saying you know just derogatory
to a woman i was like why you think you
think women don't also talk about one
night stands and you think women also
don't talk about slapping me around and
and you know like
it's
there are sensitive people in the world
good luck
no i'm totally with you i mean we could
do a whole show talking about you know
freedom of speech and
derogatory words because like who cares
honestly i think it's great i think it's
fun i think life-changing money is
hilarious i thought it was brilliant um
and if anyone has a problem with it then
they that oh my god they've got more
problems they've got to deal with
because that is literally
a problem with it then everything is
cool
there you go perfect that's all that
matters well ron i want to thank you so
much um and i want to thank everybody
for watching um and interacting it's
been really fun reading through all your
comments um and i'm really excited to
potentially come on crypto banter then
amazingly we look forward to having you
and thank you thank you thank you love
this we should do it again
for sure alright guys we'll see you next
week bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]